siete pronti a provare l'errore e le
cose da scott e con me come sempre
segnato di quanti punti avete fatto e
alla fine del video vediamo se avete di
cui ho scritto io
se volete vedere altri giochi e sistemi
lasciate un bel live mi raccomando leif
meritano tantissimo quindi nostre più
belle life stories penn e ora siete
pronti
iniziando che allora c'era scritto che
ci sono dei panda nascosti in ogni
immagine c'è scritto che se riesce a
risolvere a risolvere almeno 16 6 più
intelligente addirittura ok quello al
margine abbiamo solo 10 secondi per
provare per trovarla non provarlo e
prati via o chi lo trovate lo proposte
ragazzi però sebbene guardate bene
invece stupito che sbuca ok perfetto
prima che lo faccia vedere video e poi
ho trovato io ecco anno e quindi ios
avevo un punto se anche voi l'avete
trovato avete fatto un punto numero due
ok ragazzo di secondi di ritrovo non lo
trovo ok l'ho visto ho vissuto la mia
per tenete bene guardate bene tanto
tanto inseguimenti sta bene perché lo
stesso colore dei pupazzi di neve
ok vi dico dove l'ho trovato io eccolo
qua il bandino vediamo giusto fini
allora fanno due punti vedi uso di
favorito per sensi così vediamo schiocco
di intelligenze numero 3
oddio
ok l'ho visto l'ho visto ragazzo rete
bene e super mimetizzato po proponete
bene no significative 3 pausa prima di
farvelo vedere vabbè allora non prendo
nessun punto rimangono due punti ce
l'avevate individuato prima che il video
lo potete vedere prendete un altro furto
anche numero 4 oddio qui difficilissimo
[Musica]
ok l'ho visto è molto piccolo ragazzi e
muscolo parte bene quindi visto poteva
dare dove lo individua trio
eccolo qua con il sistema infatti molto
difficile vederlo perché super piccolo
però eccolo qua il sale a tre punti
anche voi un punto in pista l'aver
individuato sia quello numero 5 dai
questo modo i nostri più rapidi oddio
[Musica]
[Applauso]
ok lo individuato ragazzi corte bene è
ben nascosto orobico dove lo straw fatto
io
[Musica]
eccolo qua era nascosto benissimo
vediamo se è giusto si viva quindi salvo
a 4 punti mi sembra numero 6
[Applauso]
oddio non lo vedo da nessuna parte ma
non trova dietro non si credo voi siete
riusciti a trovarlo numero 7 ok trovato
trovato individuato questo è più facile
guardate bene
[Applauso]
ok metto paura ecco qua sto benissimo
cinque punti numero 8 come senza fare la
parola panda o dio cosiddetti filo dei
secondi
[Musica]
impossibile dal rumore questo
[Applauso]
[Musica]
era troppo difficile questo numero 9
oddio aiuta o che non hanno mai trovato
e alimenti tantissimo perché sembra un
cane anche questo quella tempo
eccolo qua allora penso che sia un po
alla rocca vediamo se sì cosa sei punti
numero 10
ok
l'ho visto l'ho visto è un bando
arrabbiato guardate bene ok per fare
dopo ha individuato e con panda
arrabbiato quindi senso fa qualcosa che
tutti mi sembra si mette punti prossimo
numero punti
[Musica]
ospiti che si sono buttati qua sopra
mannaggia riuscivamo a fare 16 punti
numero 12
[Musica]
[Applauso]
quali meditatissimi vada bene anche qua
cosa era riutilizza tizio questo per
fare a 7 punti non monta ellis ok quello
individuato subito il vino finalmente
un'altra che resta da sbloccare guardate
bene che fermo ecco come fan di nomi di
un vetusto finita ma otto punti sono
falliti numero 14
[Musica]
ma questi sono tutti i fan o no forse
pugni a trovare quello che abbia solo i
ciechi e non le strisce oddio
impossibile no nome divino dovuto
buttarmi vantaggio queste riusciti a
individuarne il tempo numero quindi si
[Musica]
[Applauso]
aiuto
[Musica]
non vedo nessun pazzo e mezzo e colore
con quei nomi vietatissimo qualche
sentiero vorrei essere nove punti giusto
9 punti
riuscirò arriva la sensi pentolino
numero estensi
[Musica]
oddio
[Applauso]
[Musica]
voi siete riusciti a vederlo non male 17
forse uno visto l'ho visto l'ho visto è
viva ok e dicono bene
ecco qua tanto a 10 punti finalmente s'è
trovato il numero 18
ho visto subito come subito viva
guardate bene a facile questo che faccio
vedere dov'è
ecco nino salvo 11 punti si viva uniti
punti numero 19 questo e per ultimo
[Musica]
[Applauso]
con lo trovo ferri l'utilizzatissimo
maledetto numero 20 l'ultimo treno poi
l'ho vista la vetta si transita su
vedere proprio nel 2008
ecco la viva a tanta 12 punti ok allora
dobbiamo trovare un ombrello in questi
struzzi bene un ombrello un ombrello
l'avete trovato voi prima l'ho vista
l'ho visto il mio ottimamente trovato a
ecco qua era mimetizza tissimo prossima
foto qua bisogna trovare il fungo
oddio
[Musica]
eccolo l'ha visto ragazzi vedete bene
per atene è molto simile almeno tutto e
quindi eccolo qua prossima dobbiamo
trovare una tartaruga poi mezzo il 45
secondi ok
[Musica]
no l'altro non la trovo ragazzi
credetemi nei commenti dov'è non la vedo
da nessuna parte
[Musica]
due no incredibile ragazzi non l'altro
va da nessuna parte
mi arrendo iscrivetevi voi la risposta
nei commenti che ultimo dobbiamo trovare
un bruco in mezzo questi sushi un no
sono troppo difficile stimati non trovo
nessun trucco
[Musica]
ecco l'unica che non vendo qui in alto è
questa della tartaruga non riesco a
vederlo da nessuna parte
se voi l'avete vista qualche parte qua
nella foto scrive tv nei commenti dove
così riesco a vederla anch'io scrive
simili commenti quanti punti avete fatto
io
nell'altro 13 in questo nel nominato due
quindi 15 scrivetevi se mi avete battuta
se volesse vedere altri del gender
studies line che vi lascio al 44 giri su
cui potete cliccare per vedere i
prossimi video poi si spara trasmessa al
entro i prossimi giochi clicca su quello
che preferite buona visione
[Musica]